[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
permettez moi également y voir regarder
ce que c'est dans tpm p merci bb&t belle
isabelle une élève sympathique mais qui
a redoublé quelques classes en raison
notamment du syndrome gilles de la
tourette dont elle est atteinte c'est
pas tarder à matthieu delormeau d'un
bordel à queue on le sait puisque elle
le dit environ 30 fois par émission isa
est également une élève de l'école rtl
et à force de côtoyer laurent gerra
chaque matin elle se transforme parfois
en imitatrice a comme vous diriez cyril
[Rires]
servi au bout du rouleau
côté comportement isa est une élève
dissipé qui n'hésite pas à violenter ses
petits camarades
hier sept nuls 10 lots pour une fois
mais ce qui est le plus douloureux
feyisa ce ne sont pas ses coûts ce sont
ces blagues trois services et bien mr
c'était déjà arrivé un mec que tu kiffes
est grave
oui plus de la gueule alors quelle note
pour isabelle
mais la bonne voie
[Rires]
il fut j'arrive encore longtemps
ça démarre très bien mise à part une
bosse qu'il est coiffé viendra nous
donner votre note dans un instant
regardez à la déboule si vous voulez
aller boire des verres au club attention
on va démarrer par vous benhaim alors
miley avait rêvé d'aller oui la
marocaine la loi il n'a jamais commencé
par les choses qui fâchent les points
négatifs mais tu sais que je t'aime mais
tout de même tu râles beaucoup tu râles
toute l'émission je te vois marc monnet
à l'oreille de tes petits camarades tout
le temps et d'ailleurs je vois là
raymond cloche la tête comme ça en
disant oui elle parle pendant toute
l'émission elle marmonne par ailleurs
tué violente is as tu frappes t pour une
camarade tu frappes gilles qui le
méritent et tu frappes mathieu qui le
méritent mais quand même tu frappes
et puis parfois tu es tellement fatigué
qu'il t'arrive de faire des micro sieste
pendant l'émission mais ça en battant
vouloir évidemment tu as énormément de
points positifs puisque tu connais le
monde de la télé comme sa poche
tu as des analyses extrêmement
pertinentes qui est très drôle même si
parfois tes vannes sont un peu éculé
comme on a pu le voir
et puis bah bref c'est indispensable à
tpm paix et je t'aime et c'est pour ça
que je te mets un gros set
ça ne va pas donc pas si ça va prendre
la tête et il amène côté le gynéco sur
la tête de ma mère était comme est chez
comme celui-là il venait de rencontrer
son bord le contrôle de maths faire la
une je sais pas la 3g paris visite
hilale 4 non plus parallélépipède
séparer vite et pourquoi
qu'est ce que tu as non non tout va bien
ta mère tu as besoin de boire un coup un
[Rires]
g2 et de l'os yeux ouais je vais jamais
dans le service
[Applaudissements]
c'est historique gynéco qui boit de
l'eau là les gars je vous le dis je
demande une jeune homme en une alerte
peugeot bat morgane
alors oui quand même pas capable du dos
il va rouillé waouh quoi essayer ça
c'est vrai ouais alors n'en voit pas
trop ouais se voir s'ils voient des
glouglous n'y a pas de groupes c'est
comment alors ça se fait dans le dos ça
va le remettre
oui j'aime isabelle vous savez que dans
le cas de mon activité je vois beaucoup
de personnes âgées et vous êtes bien la
preuve que la vieillesse n'est pas un
naufrage
vous avez tous connus des écus les
anciens francs les nouveaux franc l'euro
et malgré ça vous êtes toujours là vous
avez réussi à passer de du télégramme
instagram malgré vous remettre votre
humanisme
du coup j'ai décidé de vous donner un
point par décennie que vous avez vécu
pour gémissent alors vous donner la
suite
mais petit bémol vous ne connaissez pas
mon prénom vous m'appelez tout temps
mohamed vous aimez bernard de la
villardière j'ai donc décidé de vous
mettre 4 diviser a d'autre part 2 ouais
bravo jimmy
je ne dis pas bravo pour le cas je ne
dis pas bravo pour le 4 mai je dis bravo
pour le oui/non
[Rires]
c'était bien vu qu'ils ont fait ça jabra
prof s'appelait monsieur le bop
ils dégradent travers moi il faisait
comme un allègement les copies on y va
jean michel maire qui bossent pas toi
mais tu bosses pas toile et 16 hanouna
c'est pas mal ça fait des efforts toit
d'un 1 1 2 et niveau 2 sur le gazon
alors oui jean michel onfray
oui isabelle bonjour à vous les voulez
jouer non je suis un peu malade j'ai une
laryngite que je suis sonné par jimmy
voilà mais c'est encore là sont des
données par jimmy vous serez le guéry
très vite il m'envoyait l'ordonnancé
1h30 du matin c'est une ode à 1h30 du
matin ils voulaient faxer en boîte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul la campagne tenu de faire
ses bagages
ça va un peu mieux mais c'est de l'art
agitée avec beaucoup d'humour mais j'ai
pas lu lors de nancy me l'envoyer quand
je t'ai donné à la firme rcd afin
d'affirmer à la pharmacienne s'est
décrit viagra de suguenot merci d'amiens
dont la plus tard c'est raide il a
écouté bain en tout cas prenez les deux
noms savage a pas de problème comme vous
comme vous je dis j'en aurai way we may
pas sous-entendre que les prem direction
je veux dire tu as well as padilha plus
dans le voisinage que deux directions
je suis à combler pour les deux oui la
belle tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup ça
fait sept ans je crois qu'on est qu'on
est ensemble sur ce plateau
voilà mais je veux ça m'a pas empêché de
t'attaquer sur le physique c'est ce que
je préfère que des athées piment
d'espelette quota autour du cou je n'en
peux plus voilà ce que tu étais habitué
vous rhabiller en rouge et on doit
essayer de changer de région et même si
je suis du sud ouest change de région la
saucisse et la saucisse de morteau 18 du
bar one ce que tu veux mais change un
peu de régions le sud ouest en remercier
2éme en tbt avis tu as pas d'avis
tranché c'est toujours ta dah
en revanche alors j'ai fini par
comprendre au bout de sept ans pourquoi
c'est que tu as 5 montre autour des
poignets il a pas une qui dit la même
heure ont forcément on a du mal à se
repérer quand on a pas une demande qui
donne la même heure et dernièrement et
blagues ça faisait peut-être rire autant
des pyramides dans les tranchées au
moyen âge mais on en 2019 franchement
les comment vas tu veux toi et toile à
matelas et vole mes lampes et blagues
franchement je t'en remercie m et je
t'aime quand même beaucoup ont jeté mais
une lettre ''voyage thémis saint ouen
et là je l'espace main à qui a acquis la
cantonade acquis cantona eric cantona
les yachts là c'est bon on se calme
vous avez donné votre mac oui bien sûr
je donnais ma note by isabelle c'est un
peu notre questionnement de deux
services mais la voyait oui je l'avoué
[Rires]
voilà c'est au bras je vous le rappelle
voilà bel et bien donc c'est notre casse
bonbons de service et je trouve que
cette année tu as fait des progrès tutu
marc même - et hugo de moins fin c'est
plutôt agréable
c'est vrai j'ai remarqué le vendredi et
surtout et c'est donc effectivement tu
connais c'est vrai les médias très bien
mais mes tontons poste à m6 et rtl fait
que tu n'étais pas de débat la tétée pas
honnête mais ça c'est ton problème
voilà tu n'aime que des millions
d'hommes 6 mai en revanche pour parler
comme toi je t'aime beaucoup et tu est
excellente je devais donc un très beau 7
allez j leaque l'a compris principe non
te casse pas là non on va te revoir tout
à l'heure alors - bonsoir alors moi pour
des points certes je devais faire très
court
elle est parfois sensibles parfois trop
sensible pour les points fait parfois
meeting pour les points positifs je
trouve qu'elle est très bonne camarade
bonne joueuse et parfois ils encaissent
sans rien dhien comme qu elle s est fait
mal par exemple en tunisie
elle ne l'a pas dit donc elle râle
parfois comme ça a été dit mais
s'ouvrait lanka sans rien dire et pour
ça j'ai mis un très beau 8 et mathieu la
coupe du monde huit bébés
isabelle est un peu comme un les vieux
tableau que je vois dans les salons de
chez mes grands parents on sait pas très
bien si ça a de la valeur est ce que ça
fout là qu'en même temps on n'a pas
envie de s'en séparer alors on regarde
voilà tu souris tout le temps dans
l'émission un peu comme maintenant
j'aime aussi si tu étais heureuse tu
comprenais rien ne bouge alors qu'à ses
côtés devant tout le temps tu un peu à
partenaires à moteur de ma deuxième
testicules donc taxi à côté de moi tout
le temps tu es important cette année
encore c'est de pire en pire tu marmol
tout le temps geneviève de fontenay à
côté de moi tes dents au comportement
d'un peu tout le temps sous la selle
après huit ans qui coûte une parler
quand la caméra n'est pas sûr elle voit
vraiment que tu comprennes le principe
pour le reste mon coeur tu travailles
beaucoup chaque émission dont tu parles
tu en parles mal mais tu l'as vu c'est
déjà pas mal
donc je t'appelle tout le temps d'animer
je devrais appeler m'amuse car je tiens
beaucoup à toi je t'aime beaucoup mon
petit chou et sebo donc avec cet amour
et son talent méritait pas écrit la
belle note de 16 et ça avait du coeur
jay z avait déjà mis ça n'a pas tué
raymond est resté vraiment aux pieds les
coûts et kelly vas-y vas-y raymond bon
moi je vais la finir isa ça a été ma m'a
quand même un petit peu ma curiosité isa
quand je suis arrivé à tes papiers comme
la femme à barbe
non mais c'est vrai n'hésitez de deux
ore comment les gens aiment bien voici
et à chaque fois je me disais mais elle
a fait semblant de rire ll est toujours
parti pris pour pour m6 à lyon quand je
suis arrivé ici j'ai vu de la
bienveillance statut m'a toujours donné
des petits conseils tu m'as dit aussi
quand ça allait pas moi j'aime bien ce
que tu dis tu m'a soutenu avec bella
avec valérie et les autres mais il ya un
truc qui m'a gêné c'est que je te trouve
plus drôle quand je suis chez moi que
quand je suis là quand je suis là j'ai
l'impression parfois comme à dire tu
t'endors l'impression que tu dors j'ai
l'impression que parfois tu me
demandes-tu dit la lfp s'est passé quoi
là il a dit quoi
donc chaque mois sur ces quatre cinq
mois je n'ai pas trouvé très efficace
malgré que tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup qu'on s'envoie des pitres le
matin parce qu'on a le point commun
entre relever tous les deux à cinq
heures du matin
donc je t'ai mis un petit si je vais
finir parce que cyril fait djo donc
j'étais mis un petit 6 ita
pas facile de conseils de classe avec un
rampant d'objets des coûts oui moi je
t'ai mis 10
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui et donc ouais bien je parle
pas par personne interposée j'aime voir
les gens en face d'élèves on leur parle
dans les yeux et toi tu es quelqu'un
d'assez extraordinaire
têtu passe pas par monts et par vaux
pour dire ce que tu as à dire 10 taldir
c'est parfait moi j'aime parler avec toi
tu est agréable et en plus c'était super
intelligente n'essayait pas de suivre de
monter dans des trains qui ne concerne
pas tu es toujours dans la bonne glace
moi je te suis ou de suivre on peut
aller avec toi on peut les compter
ouais on comprend ce qu'il dit et puis
aussi tissé être fier bras la vie tels
maux par les mots cités réfléchi tout ça
entre nous ça peut coller les branches
et c'est vachement parfait merci et vous
votre chat lot voit très bien
ouais j'ai par les spectateurs alors
déjà voulez vous voir il y revient elle
elle revient faisceau chine où tout ça
dans deux ans isabelle morini-bosc la
saison prochaine étape et oui à 79
non la note d allez on y va à la note
sur twitter merci 7 7 61 salle est belle
est ce que ça va mal
oui alors oui bonsoir et est arrivé par
derrière jaime pascal voulez chez moi en
fait mais c'est vous que je regarde ton
parfois cela tenait non moi je pars
quand je regarde la caméra web a alors
pensé que le fait de la téloche lien
entre internet et moi c'est que vous
m'avez gueule à plusieurs reprises en me
disant marmonne pas et j'ai fait un gros
effort sur moi même depuis plusieurs
semaines ont pas marre elle marmonne
plus on remarque que les gars merci
merci ca
[Applaudissements]